- My favorite teacher,
I had, I was lucky too.
I had about three or four
that really impacted my life.
But I would say the one
that impacted me most
was my drama teacher from high school.
His name was Christopher
Hasket and his nickname is Kit.
He still lives in Orlando.
And he was the first
teacher that when I said
I wanted to be a stand-up
comic and an actor.
Oh, what a great shot, I
don't know how you guys got-
- Yeah, we do our homework, Billy.
- You know, he was the first
teacher that took me seriously.
And I think the good teachers know
that sometimes all the
kids don't quite fit into
the rest of the group.
And that maybe some kids
need to be connected with
on a different level.
And, you know, he was the
first real adult teacher
that took me serious
in what I wanted to do.
You know, I wanted to be
a comedian and an actor.
And I told some of my teachers that,
and you know, they had me pegged
for ending up working at a Chevron.
And that's okay, that
would have been okay too.
But he was the teacher
that said, you know man,
if you really want to do this,
it's not enough to dream it.
You have to put your time in.
You have to put your work in.
And then I had to do my senior year over
and I only had three or four classes
that second senior year.
And told me, he said,
instead of going home
or screwing off or taking a nap,
he said, come to the auditorium
and learn to build sets with me.
And let's talk about, let's
talk about what it takes.
Let's talk about New York,
Chicago, Los Angeles.
Let's talk about what
you want to go after.
Let's talk about television,
film, theater, Broadway.
And he just had an impact,
not only educationally on my life,
but talking to me
seriously and then saying,
yeah you can do this, but
I'm not going to lie to you
there's so much work involved.
So you have to take it seriously.
Take your fun seriously,
is what he would say to me.
Take your fun seriously.
And he just had a huge impact in my life
and I will love him forever for that.
I really will.